so today we're going to be talking about
the lasso yes this is I'm pretty sure
this is John Wayne but wrong glass so
we're going to talk about the
mathematical lasso so the lasso is this
equation essentially your goal is that
you have an objective function you're
trying to minimize all of machine
learning is just minimizing something
and depends how you're going about
minimizing it so who here has seen the
lasso alright so a lot of you hopefully
like this hoping a lot of you see this
basically the left-hand side is ordinary
least squares you minimize that you have
linear regression we've been doing that
for a few hundred years the right-hand
side is a penalty term the it's the l1
norm of the beta's that is the sum of
the absolute values of betas times is
lambda that's your penalty term we could
also do the ridge but today we're just
going to focus on the last so similar
solutions for both but just the last so
today geometrically we're talking about
the blue diamond on the inside so that
has sharp edges and that's when it gives
you the singularities which gives you a
variable selection similar it lets you
do variable selection that's actually
you know kosher to do so we're going to
start with the data because about data
what are we showing here and for our
example we're going to use a just a
portion of the aims housing data there's
more of it but it's not on the screen
right now normally there'd be like a
whole bunch of little red dots clustered
around the downtown of Ames if you can't
see it unfortunately here and we're
using this because it's available but
also because it's not a lot of rows but
it does have a lot of columns for the
number of rows which is where the last
so excels that's what it was invented
for it was actually invented for
genomics when you had 5,000 columns but
only a thousand rows so this is really
great for high dimensional data getting
the data is pretty easy you use Eames
housing package make Eames and then you
split the data using the our sample
package and you get into a training and
testing split
the data has a lot of information about
the sale price of the of the house you
have the latitude and longitude square
feet quality a bunch of different
qualities quality of the house quality
of the kitchen quality of the basement
all this good stuff so let's do some
data prep there's an old joke I'm sure
everyone's heard of here so I'm gonna
give you a groaner 80% of the time is
spent doing data preparation the other
20% of the time is complaining about
data preparation so we're gonna start
off like you do anything else an hour
for modeling with a formula you can see
we have many many variables lots of them
sale price will be our outcome variable
our response and we're going to regress
that on all these other input variables
we're going to be using us a lot of
times so instead of retyping it we just
save it as a variable that's new to a
lot of people they didn't they don't
realize you could save a formula as a
variable but it's a really handy thing
to do we're gonna take this formula and
put it into a recipe so we're gonna take
this recipe which is like the new
cutting-edge cool hip way of defining
your design matrix instead of relying on
the old semantics of a formula which I
know we are using formula to get started
we didn't have to but this sort of makes
it more explicit what you're going to do
like for instance step other we were
taking any categorical variable has many
levels and the least frequent of them
grouping them into other we are getting
rid of any variables of zero variance
which means they don't provide really
any information centering and scaling
all the numeric variables and creating
dummy variables and in this case we are
not chopping the baseline there are K
levels we are getting K dummy variables
because of the lasso you don't need to
worry about collinearity and we're
adding an intercept explicitly because
if you don't the model might not give it
to you after you defined our recipe you
then go and prep the recipe you get it
ready and this is going to do things
like calculate the mean and standard
deviation of each of the numeric columns
it's going to figure out what levels of
the categoricals are available this way
it can be applied the same way from the
training data to the testing data and
I'd like to see model that matrix do
that this is much better and by saying
retain that means when we want to
for training data it's much faster so
there are many ways we can fit the lasso
and we're going to look at a bunch of
them today because we can people who
know me let know that I'd like to give
my talks like let's do it an art because
we can and just you know do everything
so first up glim net yes it's pronounced
glim net i used to pronounce the GLM net
then it got a lunch with the author of
the package and he said no it's
pronounced gloom net and i've been
crushed ever since so came up with hasty
trip johnny and friedman like the
godfathers of machine learning and glib
net was written in 73 lines of Fortran
code that's insane how little code that
took right it's amazing so we start off
with our matrices we get our X input
matrix our Y output matrix and for the
input matrix we're going to use a DGC
matrix that's a sparse matrix the
benefits are it takes up less space in
memory but it also computes faster
sparse matrices have faster computation
so we take our prepped recipe object and
we juice it and this is how we get the
training data out of there yes you're
gonna be juicing and baking Thank You
max so we're gonna be doing this you not
to do the calculations again that's the
benefit of juicing we get our X and why
we call gloom net one line of code to
call gloom net to give us penalize
regression give you the x given the y
we're going to explicitly say it's a
Gaussian model and alpha equals 1 which
means it's explicitly saying it's a
lambda don't include the intercept
because our design matrix have that has
that already and don't include don't
standardize the data because we've
already standardized everything in
recipes one line of code to fit an
entire path of regressions so when you
do glim net
it doesn't fit one model it fits roughly
a hundred models one for each lambda and
ends up looking like this
each line is a coefficient and for a
given value of lambda it tells you the
value of that coefficient further away
from the zero line the bigger the impact
as you increase lambda you're increasing
the penalty the variables gets shrunk
down and eventually some of them go
straight to zero and they've not been
selected that's your variable selection
and we've all seen this pot if you've
done
and y'all like how do I read this which
one is which there is a label argument
but it's nearly useless so fortunately
there's an interactive version in the
co-op package you can call Co of path
and it'll give you an interactive
visualization if I wasn't giving a
presentation I could hover over this and
it'll pop up a legend showing you the
values and you can even zoom in and pan
around and see the different values of
your graph here I think it's a big
improvement over the base are plotting
and let's say out of your hundred
lambdas you've decided on one of them
and you want one you can call Co of plot
and see the point estimates for each of
the coefficients this is showing the
point estimates for a lambda of zero
point zero zero four I chose that
because I did cross-validation I did it
a bunch of times it seemed to work the
best notice there are no confidence
intervals because confidence intervals
be damned no I actually like confidence
intervals they think they're barely
really important but so much a
machine-learning doesn't include them so
we're stuck about them you can't
bootstrap this because it's a biased
estimator so the bootstrap doesn't work
you need an adjusted bootstrap though
tips Ronny did put out a package
recently that lets you get confidence
intervals but it takes more
computational power than fitting the
lasso does nice that was gloom net let's
move on to XG boost the darling of
Kaggle competitions so similar to gloom
net it takes sparse matrices you give it
an X a sparse X and a dense y but you
had to compute this xgb D matrix object
and this keeps the X&Y together and you
can tell when they built this they were
thinking of classification because they
call the input input variable data and
the output label is if the output isn't
part of your data and they call it a
label as if you're not going to do a
regression but you can totally do
regression so I have to get this special
object created you go ahead and call X G
be trained you give it the special
object holding the X&Y and the key line
here is the booster by default actually
boost fits a boosted tree but by setting
to G be linear its boosting a linear
model
now when hasty and tip Johnny came up
with gradient boosted machines it was a
machine any model could be boosted
we're gonna boost the linear model but
what we're doing is we're setting alpha
it's a different alpha now they had to
change all the names
so while glim net has the lambda and
then alpha is a mixing parameter and XG
boost alpha is the lambda Penn is the
last penalty lambda is the rage penalty
so we're going to use alpha of 0.004 to
set up a lasso regression and we use a
objective of linear regression and we
boost it 20 times when you do that you
get a co-op lot like this seems like a
similar model to before however this
shows you all the 0 variables so there's
a little trick of cough pot where you
can say don't plot it filter out
everything and then plot it again using
coop
so coop plot can take data frames in
addition to models it's a little bit of
effort so Cove plots going to be updated
so that it's one step you don't need to
use filter in there so next up is Lars
least angle regression this is one of
the early functions for doing the lasso
written by hasty tips Ronnie and Efron
Bradley Efron the inventor of the
bootstrap so for this we need dense
matrices you can no longer use sparse
matrices so again we use juice from the
recipes package and we say composition
is matrix with our dense matrices we
call VARs this is from the Lars package
notice it looks very similar to gloom
net you have your X your Y the type is
lasso no intercept don't normalize and
like lasso unlike XG boost this will fit
the entire path of lambdas not just one
of them and glim that actually gets
faster when you put a hundred than when
you fit one it's pretty cool so there is
no coffee pot function built into this
so the extra at the coefficients
restored it's the data frame we add in
our non-existing confidence intervals
because there we don't get them and you
call a coffee pot on this constructed
data frame and once again we are getting
similar results as we would hope because
we keep fitting the lasso
so then we come to Stan easy an MC MC
now we could write this in pure Stan
code we could write all the stand code
of all the blocks but we're just going
to use our stand arm because it's all
built for us the reason we can use stand
is because the lasso can be interpreted
as a Laplace prior it's not exactly the
same that you have to talk about the
mode versus the mean but it's close
enough for our purposes that you put a
Laplace prior on your coefficients
you're going to get the lasso so thanks
to this little trick we can do this but
Stan is written for statisticians so it
uses data frames so we need to go back
to recipes it's almost identical except
we're not creating dummy variables we
are leaving them as categorical because
stamp will take care of that for us so
we create a recipe and then we juice it
and this time we say the composition is
a Tibble
so we've seen sparse matrices dense
matrices and Tibbals all available
thanks to the recipes package so given
this data frame and the formula we
created a while ago we call Stan GLM and
yes this is G LM not Glyn we give it the
formula and we give you the data frame
tell it to Gaussian and we say the prior
is lasso now stan has a Laplace prior
which we could have used but then you
need to specify the parameter you need
to specify the penalization parameter
and I don't want to do that by using the
lasso prior able to learn the hyper
parameter from the data so yes it takes
longer because you're doing you have to
do MCMC on this but I don't do any
variable tuning I don't have to do hyper
parameter tuning it does it by itself
sort of like cross-validation in glib
net so this is really really awesome
left let's it all happen automatically
so Stan has its own version of coop lot
called MC MC intervals which gives you
confidence intervals we finally got them
back for the lasso
thanks to Bayesian statistics so Bayes
to the rescue here I don't know how to
sort it yet I'm gonna have to ask them
how to do that
but a nice feature of Bayes that you
don't need to just get the intervals you
can get the density of your betas this
shows you for each beta each coefficient
where the mass of it is and where its
most likely where it's less likely and I
really love the fact that you get an
entire distribution not just the
interval all right next up quadratic
programming because we can why not do it
so back to our loss function that we saw
before the sum of squares plus a penalty
will get rid of the 1 over 2 n because
it's a constant and we rewrite it in
matrix notation the l2 norm of the
objective plus the l1 norm of the
penalty this is now an unconstrained
quadratic optimization problem and the
lambda is the Lagrangian rewrite this as
a constrained optimization where now
it's just the objective function the sum
of squares subject to the sum of the
beta's being less than T and T is
inversely proportional to our old lambda
so let's take our objective function and
do some matrix arithmetic you know all
we did was took the transpose properly
we did foil
yes we're foiling from like middle
school it's matrix foil we expanded out
we rate rearrange some terms and we get
that bottom line there you get to that
bottom line and you can rewrite this in
quadratic optimization notation which
looks like this and the optimizers have
slightly different notation for us X is
our data and the betas are our unknowns
that we're trying to solve for for
quadratic well optimization people in
general X is the unknown variable that
they're solving for so in our case we
have betas they have X's so you just
need to rewrite it that way in order to
rewrite it that way we need to do a
little mathematical trick and we need we
say the positive side of beta minus the
negative side of beta and that's a trick
if you do the beta plus minus beta minus
it gives you beta and by doing it this
way I know I'm going through this really
quickly but it's a 20-minute talk by
doing it this way you if you didn't do
it this way you would have to have 2 to
the P
constraint formulas and that's too many
to do so by splitting up into the
negative portion of the positive portion
we dramatically reduce the number of
constraint equations we need and it will
allow us to optimize this quicker so
there's no program to do this
automatically so we need to write our
own custom function like this now I took
this from this guy Eric Drysdale has a
wonderful write-up of doing quadratic
optimization for the lasso essentially
you're computing all those V and X
matrices and all those vectors and then
you're fitting a regular linear model to
get the upper bounds for the
coefficients and that sort of a glim
that does it computes the dot product
between each predictor and the response
to figure out the top values but the
cure the crux of it here is the bottom
we do low rank Q P low rank quadratic
programming it's quadratic programming
but since we have sparsity it needs to
be low rank so it's a special function
to do that we give it all of our
matrices and vectors we created with all
of our constraints which I'm not going
to walk through right now and that's our
function we can use we then build our
matrices again thanks to the recipes
package and then we call our function
like this one line of code after writing
20 lines of code you give it your x and
y and he give it a T and the T you would
need to tune I chose 5 and I chose it
cuz it looked good in the pictures and
it conversion 25 iterations and yes
there is a there's a guarantee how
quickly this will converge I forget the
exact number but there's a guarantee it
will converge in like a short amount of
time we get the coefficients and it
looks like this nice varsity it didn't
choose all the variables that actually
did its job all right so that's
quadratic programming back to easier
code tensorflow
tensorflow is essentially just a
generalized matrix algebra library so
you can do linear regression is
essentially a wrapper around eigen
that's really what it is underneath the
hood
so for tensor flow we need dense
matrices once again because it can't do
sparse but also it can iterate data into
memory so it's not a big deal
we then design our network and our
network consists of one layer it's the
output layer and uses a linear
activation function if it's a linear
activation function it's a linear
regression especially since it's one
layer so we give our input and I chose
the kernel regularizer
to be l1 lasso and I chose a they call
it L our lambda of 0.02 again because it
looked good you would need to tune these
things and now the weights in a deep
learning model are just coefficients
from a linear regression and we're
instead of solving for them using newton
raphson we're gonna solve this to cast a
gradient descent so our model looks like
this 64 parameters all the numeric
variables plus all the dummy variables
plus the intercept we then compile the
model if you haven't seen Karason
tensorflow and are you don't actually
save it back to variable because you
modify it in place we're going to use
mean squared error as our loss function
and we're going to use rmsprop as our
optimizer we could have used atom but
Armas prop was fine and we have a metric
of mean absolute error and then we train
the model I think Karras took more work
even than quadratic optimization so we
give it the x and y matrix we do 30 up
books we choose our batch size is 64
smaller the better we use a 10%
validation split we do a early stopping
we do learning rate adjustment we would
call a tensor board you do all that and
you get your your metrics how you're
doing it as the epochs increase you get
better and better and it appears we have
not yet started to overfit so that's a
good thing so now that we have a 1 layer
model it's no longer black box we get
coefficients you can get that you get
the weights and if it's one layer it's a
linear model so you can understand it
it's an interpretable neural net
who would have ever thought you can get
that so we did all the models let's very
quickly look at performance because a
lot of people think machine learning is
just like a game we try to get the
highest score so we take our test data
and we can no longer juice now we bake
the test data and so we bake our data
test data and we make predictions for
each of the models with the exception of
quadratic programming which is just
matrix multiplication everything even
Karis uses the predict function we each
one might be a little different new X
versus new Y
apparently baking might change the order
of the the variable columns so that's
something that we need to get fixed so I
had to do it there and you have little
things here but it's all the same for
each of these we go through add in the
actual values calculate the residuals
and put them all together as a data
frame allowing us to make this plot this
shows us our actual values versus our
predicted values and ideally you want
them to be as close to the diagonal line
as possible let's just get the mean
squared error for each of these when we
do that stand one Stan was the best I'm
so proud of the Bayesian z-- + XG Bruce
came in like almost tied with Stan
followed by glim net VARs my car genetic
programming model followed by Karis now
I'm not saying any of these are better i
hyper tuned more some more than other
cause glim net ez a hyper tuned XG boost
fairly easy Kara's took a little more
time in truth that Karis model took
about 10 seconds to run on this laptop
on battery mode not terrible but I
didn't spend as much time doing it so
today we learned glim net XG boost Lars
stand quadratic programming and carrots
and we did it all with all of these
packages so these ties will be available
you can check out all the packages we
use today so thank you very much
you